we're currently in the círculo de la
Torre in the city centre of Turin and
we've come here to take part in the Euro
Science open forum or eise off 2010
which is taking place all over the city
so we turned up here on Sunday having
had a trek a real journey by plane than
train then buses taxi you name it
virtually every form of transport was
taken in the converse time we are
expecting an audience to fill most if
not all of these seats I have never done
any lecture especially a demonstration
chemistry demonstration literature in an
ocular room like this I mean looking at
it's stunning frescoes columns
chandeliers
to
this is out of the woods
long
professors in England are always too
busy
so I'm putting the Rosie and you can see
and they've done half so if I bang them
together they break
the couple contact at each other changes
fathers for cold